We're going to assume that we have
what we know is a random oracle,
which is an ideal cryptographic hash function.
And this random oracle assumption means that we can have
an ideal cryptographic hash function
that match any input to H with a uniform distribution.
And, an attacker trying to find collisions
can do no better than a brute force search on the size of H.
So, that's what we will assume we have.
Before we go forward with that assumption,
I want to ask a quiz--whether random oracles actually exist.
The answers are: Yes, they do, and we know of one;
maybe they exist but we don't know of one yet;
or, no, it's impossible to actually build a random log.